hey everybody and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be showing
you um as you can see by the title how
to customize um basically customize a
lot of the menus and stuff in microsoft
word 2007. now first thing i got to tell
you is that it is easter today so happy
easter if you do celebrate it and um i'm
just going to say that i won't be
uploading very many videos over the next
week because i will be on vacation
visiting people etc
um so yeah don't look out for any uh
videos basically but i have a ton of
stuff coming in the mail so there will
be a lot more hardware when i come back
so here we go we i'm going to maximize
microsoft word here and in order to
basically all the customization features
are available when you hit the orb and
go down here to word options this may
have you may have already known this and
i've changed already my color scheme to
black no big deal but what we're going
to do to customize the actual menus is
just go down here to the customize
button
now you can see here these five buttons
are what i've suggested or what i have
told to be in the quick access toolbar
and here up here is my actual quick
access toolbar so it's very accurate in
uh showing what i've selected and here
are all the ones you can add to your
quick access toolbar as you can see
there are quite a few now if i do end up
emailing a lot of attachments to people
and i want to just have a quick
email quick access button i'll just
hover over email and either double click
it or just hit the add button so there
you can see it is added to the quick
quick toolbar so i just hit ok and there
you go there's the layout button so if i
have written
something and i want to email as an
attachment then i can always do that now
i haven't saved it yet so i can't but
there you go
here's another thing i can customize
let's go back to the orb and word
options again
and we're going to go to display under
display you can basically choose what
microsoft word displays to show
show hidden text to show paragraph marks
to show spaces which is kind of annoying
and to show tab characters etc and also
printing options which is very helpful
sometimes i'll be printing on a color
printer or if i'm printing on a laser
printer i want different things you can
uncheck print background colors and
images i will check that because i put
them in for a reason and stuff like that
and the last thing i want to show you is
uh the advanced button this is where a
lot of the most uh the most uh subtle
customization changes uh take place but
as you can see it says at the top
advanced options for working with word
there are a lot of cool things you can
change in here that you may not have
known have existed uh cut copy and paste
different options and usually when i
want to paste between documents i want
to keep this destination formatting you
may not even know what that means but
there you go
you might not even have known you can do
that with word so there's a whole lot of
options in here you can choose a lot of
defaults a lot of a lot of different
things that you can basically just mess
around with until you get the exact
microsoft word 2007 that you want to
work with okay so i'll just hit okay
when i'm done customizing and that is it
so i do like the black theme i like uh i
like what i've done with this and if i
ever want to edit this really quickly i
can always go to the drop down and
uncheck what i want to get rid of
so that's your basic customization in
microsoft word you may not have needed a
tutorial on that but i just felt like
showing you guys so again i won't be
coming out with very many videos this
week however i will answer emails and
answer every question i get however it
might take a little while so yeah thanks
for watching this tutorial and i hope
you like it peace